good morning of the rules
committee is called order
and we are joined in this
most August could buy a
gas assembly member works
would you introduce your
guest Joe Joe this is Joe
to everyone's job I see
nice to see you Joe Joe
yeah very nice great
to have you here -- now you with
have their of their
non voting members
very good -- PCS
vice at audio video recording
today's proceedings but
it is also being televised
-- fan of sector please
call the roll Cooley here
Cunningham their Carillo
de yeah flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove yeah Burke
somebody here Ramos here
previous year Wicks Mathis
here one we have of course
-- we have a consent
agenda is our motion on
the consent agenda acting
I was good
second of our Mister Mathis
-- affected please call the
roll Cooley high Cooley aye
Cunningham Cunningham I. Carillo
Carillo ID hi Grayson
aye Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I Burke Silva
quirk Silva aye Roman sat
Ramos aye Reavis previous
I Wicks works aye Mathis
aye the motion passes
and this rules of procedure
and thank you very much